we've got new findings to report on the
mysterious ailment called Havana
syndrome affecting U.S officials
stationed abroad now it's a result of a
multi-year investigation conducted by
five separate agencies senior
investigative correspondent that's
Catherine Herridge has been following
this story Catherine what'd they find
well good morning Gail the agencies
found that it's very unlikely the
mysterious neurological symptoms known
as Havana syndrome are the result of
actions by a foreign adversary in a
comprehensive review investigators
examined more than 1500 reported cases
symptoms range from dizziness headaches
and memory loss to cognitive impairments
so severe that some victims say they can
no longer work the new intelligence
report concluded it's very unlikely a
foreign adversary played a role and
there is no credible evidence that a
foreign adversary has a weapon the
intelligence agencies also assess that
symptoms were probably the result of
factors that did not involve a foreign
adversary such as pre-existing
conditions conventional illnesses and
environmental factors that defense
department is running its own
investigation until victims Gale that
work continues
Catherine I know that you've talked to
and you've heard these stories from more
than a dozen National Security officials
and their families who say look this is
a real thing they were deeply affected I
can't imagine what they're thinking this
morning are you hearing anything from
them I am Gail a Former Intelligence
officer told CBS news that they felt
kicked to the curb by this report these
are individuals who are trusted with
some of the nation's most closely
guarded secrets and now they say the
reporting and their analysis doesn't add
up that they can't be trusted as part of
a CBS News investigation last summer
former CIA analyst Erica Stith said she
fell ill in Europe and can no longer
work stitts told CBS News this report
implicitly blames and discredits those
who were injured while serving their
country a victim's advocacy group said
the assessment does not represent the
consensus of the full intelligence
Community instead reflecting the views
of officials interested in deflection
and closure some victims say the report
could further complicate their efforts
to get medical care and qualify for
disability though in intelligence
officials said yesterday those decisions
are separate Gail
clearly they've still got questions
Catherine thank you very much you're
welcome